We owe to socialism in this country.
Every single one of you in this room
at some point
has benefited
from the principles of the National Health Service.
Free at the point of use as a human right.
The free market
capitalist economies.
United States
has 40 million people without access to healthcare.
And the rest have to pay a great deal for it.
Where did those ideas come from?
Did they come from some benign,
very wealthy person?
Or were they.
Yes, the dreams
of people who saw their mothers dying in poverty,
saw their wives dying in childbirth grievously
because they could not afford medical care.
They wanted a communal system
that protected everybody from illness.